let's talk about three
simple easy steps
that you can fix your sciatica now
sciatica is pain that travels from your
lower back down the back part of one leg
90 of the time it comes from a disc
problem the sciatic nerve is the longest
nerve of the body and you can have pain
that goes right into your bottom of your
foot as well there's a really simple
test to determine if you have it it's
called a straight leg razor where you're
laying on your back
and you have someone just raise up one
leg at a time and as you raise it up
between 30 and 70 degrees you're going
to start feeling pain on the
affected side and you really don't need
this test because people that have
sciatica
are going to feel it on the back of one
leg now very very important okay before
i show you these three steps
i need you to rate
the intensity of your pain right now so
just write it down or put it in the
comments section right now what is your
pain right now
10 being very very severe zero being no
pain at all write that down because
we're going to ask you after we're done
to have you re-rate it now what are you
going to need in this three-step
procedure well you're going to need a
foam roller but you really don't even
need one of those you can just roll a
small towel up and you're going to need
a tennis ball but you really don't even
need that if you get someone else to do
this procedure on you so it's really
simple you're going to do three things
the first thing is we have to
reestablish the curve in your lower back
normally you should have a curve in your
lower back
but the problem with sciatica is you
lose that curve so now we have a lot of
compression on the discs and this
usually happens from sitting for long
periods of time an average person sits
between 10 and 15 hours a day that's
crazy and they usually don't sit
straight right they kind of slosh one
side so they're very susceptible to
getting sciatic nerve pain because that
disc so we want to reestablish the curve
of the lower back very simply you're
going to be putting this foam roller or
a rolled up towel
in the lower part of your back towards
about l1 not at the very lower base of
your back but a little bit up okay and
then you're going to lay on your back
for a period of time now i'm going to
show you a little clip to walk you
through that procedure okay so this is
what you do you take this little thing
right here and you're gonna place it
right on your lower back but you're not
gonna put it down here you're gonna put
it at l1 right there and you're gonna
lean back
right here
on the floor with your knees up
and it's pushing the curve up it's going
to start forming the curve you're going
to lay here for about
i don't know two or three or four or
five minutes
and
you're going to put your knees up
and you're just going to let the
foam roller push that curve up remember
don't put it like too low
raise it higher
right at about the first lumbar vertebra
so we can actually really put that curve
back it's going to take all the pressure
off the nerve and your sciatica is going
to go away so i would do this in the
morning and at night five minutes okay
we're back
for step two for this procedure you're
going to actually stimulate the opposite
sciatic nerve on the opposite leg okay
so if you have pain down the right leg
you do not want to stimulate the nerve
on the right side because it's already
hot it's swollen it's painful you're
going to stimulate the opposite side now
for this procedure i have another clip
i'm going to show you from another video
so let's let's show you how to do it
okay so let's pretend that this person
has sciatic pain on the right side now
you have to realize that sciatic
nerve comes from this point
right through the butt out down the back
of your hamstring all the way down
through this way if you have pain on the
outside through here or the front that's
not sciatica
so sanika is a big nerve it's about the
width of my thumb all the way down here
so this is what you do if you have sonic
on the right side
okay the sciatic nerve comes right out
of here
you want to work on the opposite side
okay so you'll be pressing the opposite
side
of that nerve so you'll so you'll start
right here
and there's a sacrum that comes here and
you're going to work right on the side i
could it's called the sciatic notch and
we're going to press in there
right in there and we're going to trace
down the nerve
we're going to trace down the nerve like
this
okay and you're just going to stimulate
the nerve on the opposite side it's
going to get rid of this side why
because they're on a circuit this is a
stuck standing wave and the way to get
rid of it is to work on this side again
this is one of those things where you
don't have to believe me just do it and
you'll see it works
we press right down we come right down
the center of that leg and you trace it
all the way down you can do it slowly
and work all the way down all the way
down all the way down through here now
what happens when you press on the
opposite side it's going to be very very
tender it's going to be very
probably twice as painful as this side
that hurts
and so i'm not going to get into why
that's tender but you're going to look
for the tenderness so you want to go
within that person's tolerance and just
kind of work out
that that nerve and then what you'll do
is you'll you'll work on this side and
you'll ask okay where does it hurt on
this side and they might say well now
it's shifted down here okay then we can
just do the opposite side over here okay
or maybe it's like lower in the calf
then we do the opposite side through
here so the key is never ever ever ever
work on the same side as the sciatic
nerve is work on the opposite side and
you want to get the mirror image start
from right through here work all the way
down and you might want to spend like a
couple of minutes working each spot all
the way down to the the foot okay
all right now if you don't have someone
to do this technique on you you can use
a tennis ball okay and so you basically
have to lay on your back and take the
tennis ball and put it on the opposite
side of your buttocks okay you can do
this in a chair or on your couch or on
the floor and you start to trace down
the opposite sciatic nerve and you're
going to put pressure on the nerve
starting on your buttocks going all the
way down to your hamstring on the
opposite side and you're going to be
holding this pressure until you find the
sweet spot which is the very tender spot
you're going to find that the nerve on
the good side opposite side is going to
be twice as tender or painful and that's
when you know you have the right spot so
you just keep working it down
working it down all the way down to your
hamstring and if you have pain that's
going down into your calf
then you're going to do the opposite
calf as well so that is step two okay
step three
very simply
whichever side you have the sciatic
nerve pain on you're gonna be stretching
the quadricep or the thigh muscle on the
same side
as you have pain okay so if you have
static pain down the right side the back
of your leg on the right side you're
going to be stretching your quadricep on
the right side like this
so as you can see you're going to grab
your foot you're going to bring it
forward you're going to stretch your
quadricep stretch it for a few seconds
then relax it stretch it for a few
seconds relax it so stretch it about
five times all right now that you know
the three-step procedure for sciatica
i think the next best video for you to
watch would be on inflammation what to
eat to reduce inflammation
you